قال نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه اليكساندر
نوفا كان روسيا قد تقلص انتاجها من النفط
بما يتراوحوا بين 75 في المئه في اوائل
عام 2000 و 2023 ردا على اجراءات الغرب
وضع سقفا لاسعار النفط والمنتجات
البتروليه الروسيه وكانت تسهيل التي نقلت
الخبر نقلت عن نوفاك قوله ان التخفيضات قد
تتراوحوا اذا بين
500,000 و70 100,000 برميل يوميا كما اشر
نوفاك الى ان موسكو ايضا لحضري تصدير
النفطي والمنتجات الفيتوليه الى الدول
والكيانات القانونيه التي ستطلب الامتثال
لسقف الاسعار في العقود وكان الاتحاد
الاوروبي ودول مجموعه السبع واستراليا
فرضوا حدا اقصى لسعر النفط الروسيه بلغوا
60 دولارا للبرميل وبدا سريانه في الخامس
من الشهر الجاري
للمتابعه تنضم الينا من موسكو مراسله
الجزيره رانيا جريدي يا مرحبا رانيا هل ما
نقلناها عن نوفاك هو اقصى الرد فعل سجلته
موسكو حتى اللحظه
لابد من الاشاره لان
هو فريحات الرسميه فان الرئيس
يقوم به التوقيع على الكل القرارات
المتعلقه بالرد الروسي فيما يتعلق بوضع
السقف لاسعار النفط والغاز الروسي من قبل
الدول الغربيه بدايه الاسبوع المقبل ولكن
بالطبع تصريحات التي صدرت اليوم عن نوبك
يمكن القول انها يعني تضع النقاط فوق
الحروف فيما يتعلق بالرد الروسي همم وهو
يتضمن النقطتين مهمتين النقطه الاولى وهي
ان روسيا لن تقوم بتوريد نفسها ومنتجاتها
النفسيه لاي دوله تشارك فيما يسمى بوضع
سقف لاسعار النفط الروسي هذا من جهه من
جهه اخرى روسيا يعني يمكن ان تتوجه الى
تخفيض انتاج انتاجها من النصف باطلاقا من
بدايه العام المقبل في حال تطلب الامر
والحديث يدور هنا ازدهار عن نسبه تتراوح
ما بين خمسه الى سبعه بالمئه اي الحديث
يدور عن تقليل منتوجات روسيا من النص
بمقدار 600,000 الى 700000
متر مكعب من النفط اذا يمكن القول يعني ان
هذه القرارات كانت متوقعه روس يتحدث
الكثيرا عنها في الاون الاخيره فضلا عن
ذلك انطلاقا من كل التصريحات الصادره سواء
من جانب الرئيس الروسي فالديف بودن او حتى
عن وزاره الطاقه ونائب رئيس الحكومه
الروسيه اليكساندر نوفا روسي على يقين على
ما يبدو ااه ازدهار ان ذلك لن يؤثر على
الطلب على النفط الروسي فضلا عن ذلك قبل
قليل كانت هناك تصريحات لا فده صادره الذي
تحدث عن ان روسيا حاليا تقوم به اعاده
تحويل وارداتها من همم النفط والغاز الى
الاسواق الاخرى وهنا الحديث يدور بالدرجه
الاولى عن ما تسميه روسيا الدول الصديقه
وهي الدول الاسيويه والدول الواقعه في
المحيط الهادئ فضلا عن ذلك الحديث يدور عن
الدول الافريقيه ودول ما خلاتنينيه وهنا
وادي التذكير بتصريحات سابقه كانت قد صدرت
عن الجانب الروسيه الذي قال انه طالما
كانت همم
العرض على النفط في الاسواق العالميه
محدود ولا طالما روسيا كانت من الدول
الكبرى المنتجه للنفط في العالم وطلب على
هذا النفط يعني لازالوا مطلوبا جدا في على
المستوى والصعيد العلمي طالما هذا كله
موجود فان الطلب على النفط الروسي همم
سيستمر وذلك وفقا لي القواعد التي همم
تفرضها الاسواق وليس الدول الاوروبيه التي
وضعت سقفا لهذا همم لنفط الروسي فضلا عن
ذلك الرئيس اشاره واكد ان مثل هذه
القرارات من شانها همم همم ان تتسبب بعد
عدم الاستقرار في الاسواق العالميه ستقلل
من نسبه الاستثمار على الصعيد العالمي
سترفع من اسعار موارد الطاقه على الصعيد
العالمي وكل ذلك ينعكس بالدرجه الاولى
السلبا على تلك الدول التي قامت بوضع سعر
او سقفا الى النفط الروسي والغاز الروسي
معنا من موسكو